hello everyone and welcome to the game a
lot of you have requested it's uh from
the fide grand prix andreas penko versus
hikaru nakamura and yes the news have
already most probably reached you hikaru
nakamura has qualified for the 2022 feed
a candidates tournament alongside rihard
rapport as
hikaru by winning his group in defeated
grand prix uh prevented anyone else from
really overtaking rapport who is on on
20 points
in the in the two grand priests that he
played so the two of them are qualified
and uh this is basically the game uh
that allowed hikaru to do so if you
remember in the previous video uh where
ispenko was playing against levon uh we
said that yespenko was preparing the
white pieces for hikaru and then he had
basically the black pieces against lavon
he mixed up who he was playing against
so now he will get to play his actual
preparation that he prepared in the game
versus levon it's a very interesting
game uh let's check it out and then
we're gonna discuss a little bit more
about what is happening in the uh in the
candidates so here we have e4 by
isipenko uh e5 and the bishop to c4 he
prepared the bishop's opening with
knight to f6 d3
and now knight to c6 we have knight to
c3 and now knight to a5 this is the
standard way of treating this uh
line uh we go after the light square
bishop a queen to f3 and now knight
characters and c4 d captures and d6 so
white gives up the bishop pair very
early on and he even doubles his own
pawns he has a double c pawn now and no
bishop pair but he gets pretty much the
control over the d5 square for the rest
of the game so knight g to e2 we have
bishop to e6 attacking the pawn and
isipanko defends it we have b3 bishop to
e7 and both players castle so castles
castles and now uh there is a game where
rook to d1 was played but here we have a
for by espanko and it is now as of move
10 that we have a completely new game so
hikaru goes knight to d7 makes room for
the f5 pawn to be pushed off so the
knight might be coming to at the c5 it's
a nice square
we have a5 and now a6 preventing white
from creating some uh long-term
weaknesses with uh with the pawn push to
a6 knights to g3 going after that f5
square and now bishop to g5 hikar wants
to trade bishops and get his queen into
the game so knight to f5 and now bishop
captures on c1 so this is all yeah i
find this is nothing out of the ordinary
here rook captures here and now uh first
g6 we kick away the knight from the f5
square and now knight back to e3 if you
go knight to h6 then after king h8 your
knight isn't really enjoying himself
there it's it's a very active square but
black will play a f5 and it's it could
be a little bit tricky to get it out of
there so instead knight back to e3 and
now only now c6 as the rook moved from
the a1 square we now grab
control of the center or rather try to
grab control of the center we will
prepare the d5 push but at least now we
are attacking the a5 phone so for the
moment jaspenko has to bring the rogue
back rook to a1 to defend the a5 pawn
queen to e7 and now queen to d1
we will prepare queen to d2 rook to d1
to stop black from pushing d5 so rook a
to d8 we have queen to d2 and knight to
f6 now and this knight to f6 is very
tricky by hikaru uh if white just
continues with rook to d1 hikaru will
play knight h5 and then he will gain
control over the f4 square and the white
is never playing uh pawn to f4 or rather
rotate to d1 probably as white will want
to play f4 at some point so here is
pinko without allowing hikaru to stop
this pushes f4 right away e captures on
f4 rook captures and now knight to h5
now clearing the the floor for the queen
uh rook to f3 and now queen to g5 we
have rook eight to f1 now uh and now
comes uh uh a queen captures an a5 and
this is a very interesting pawn
sacrifice
uh yes bingo wants to mount an attack
and the defeat hikaru uh and it's uh
it's not a bad move it's it's a great
move and it's a very risky move and a
very complicated one as you'll see so
queen captures an a5 hikaru doesn't have
to grab the pawn but he accepts the
challenge and now g4 now forcing the
knight to go back knight to g7 and now
knight to f5 this was the idea and the
thing is uh it's it's actually okay for
hikaru to grab this knight but it's uh
it's almost impossible to calculate that
there's simply so much stuff on the
board but to give you an example after g
captures g captures you have to play
bishop to c8 this is how you uh prevent
white from from just crushing you it
looks very dangerous i mean if f6 comes
less unlike queen g5 rook can come to g3
so it doesn't really seem like you can
defend this uh but whatever white tries
let's say queen h5 we just play f6 we
stop at the advancement of the f pawn
and after let's say rook g3 we play rook
to f7 after rook to f2 preparing to
uh
double up here on the g file we play
rook e8 and after
white
goes for this attack we can play rook to
e7 and we hold this position it looks
ugly and it looks incredibly unpleasant
to play but you know if you if you
really uh wanted to wanted to do it if
there was no other way then you could do
it hikaru declines the sacrifice he
plays queen to e5 and now his pengo goes
knight to h6 with check king to h8 and
now knight to d5 he offers another
knight and well can hikaru grab this one
uh if you play c captures we're going to
play e captures on the e5 and now you
have to play bishop captures on d5
okay maybe not have to but it is it is
the strongest move for black and after c
captures f5 and this is how you survive
the attack so it is possible but again
seems like you're just giving white too
much and you're playing right into what
white wants so here he carry plays g5
and now what do you play here well queen
to f2 or you could try maybe some c3b
for ideas on the queen side that always
uh works but here we have queen to f2
now attacking the f7 pawn four times and
now hikaru pushes f5 we have g captures
on f5 bishop captures on d5 now e
counters on d5 and knight to h5
preparing to put the knight on f4 and
then you're going to block this triple
battery white created on the f file rook
to e1 chasing away the queen queen to g7
and now only now knight to g4 now you
are hoping to get that f6 move in uh so
knight to f4 cutting off the uh queen
and rook's defense of the pawn and now
f6 luckily the knight still controls the
f6 pawn so you cannot capture it queen
to d7 uh you really want the queen here
because if you allow rook to e7 could be
very unpleasant at least now uh you are
threatening queen captures on g4 so
how can ispinko
uh uh react to this well he could defend
it with h3 then we go something like
rook d to e8 and then we trade for
example captures capture as the game
goes on but ispinko wants more uh and
again he plays rook captures on f4 and
okay g captures on f4 it's a forced move
uh queen captures and now rook did the
e8 by hikaru he offers a trade of rooks
and there really isn't anything for
andre here uh but it's uh it's again
extremely complicated and i will show it
because uh andre declined the rook trade
he played rook to f1 uh i will just show
briefly what happens after rook capture
sun e8 the thing is you cannot play rook
captures because then we play f7 and
white just wins if rook to f8 we play
queen to f6 checkmate so uh catherine
with the rook would not be very
advisable uh but after queen captures an
e8 it's uh still very much a game queen
captures on d6 we're gonna play rook to
g8 and yes you are not saving this
knight h5 is coming but after h3h5 we
can play queen to e6 uh you offer a
queen trade and after h captures on g4
you play f7 that's how you play this
queen captures on e6 pawn captures and
now g captures an h3 opening up a
discovery and trying to give up a rook
but of course
white is not interested in that white
wants to create two connected past pawns
uh or rather they are two connected past
pawns now but they want the
white will want to have both of them on
the seventh rank and then of course it's
a winning position for white so here
king h2 king g7 and now you kind of have
to capture because there's no other way
king 2f8 is coming so here we're going
to play captures and after king captures
king captures an h3 and now it's a draw
because black king will capture this
pawn
king g3 king f6 we're gonna go here
captures captures and this is now a dead
draw
so this is basically what the hikaru is
offering with rook to e8 but ispenko
again wants more rook to f1 uh and now
he car plays queen to f7 and
interestingly yes ispenko does have very
active play the knight is very dangerous
here but as long as this pawn is on f6
and uh hikaru doesn't allow him to push
it to f7 you will not be able to control
this diagonal and you will not be able
to harass the black king so here hikaru
is just much much better king h1 now
comes queen to g6 even though just
capturing on d5 as uh spank allows it is
fine again but hikar not taking any
chances queen to g6 and now we have rook
to g1 uh some complicated counter play
with c5 does exist but after rook to g1
uh there's simply no uh good move for
for white uh regardless pretty much of
what he cover plays hikaru can just set
up even further blockade with rook to f7
he can capture but he can also just play
h5 and uh it looks scary because you are
kind of forcing this uh
rook to open up on the queen but there's
really nothing white can play here a
knight to the e3 was played here hikaru
just played rook captures on f6 and he
was in this position on move 38 that
andreas pinko resigned to the game
and there as there is nothing more to be
done here and hikaru nakamura qualified
for the candidates tournament so here
you resign as you don't really have
anything if you trade queens then black
is just much much better if you try to
keep queens on the board
black can always just uh force a queen
trade and you know it's not going to be
possible to play this if you go knight
f1 we can just play rookie one or or
rook here pretty much anything just wins
we can even capture on d5 see captures
now play rook here or rook here uh
if the knight moves we happily trade if
the rook moves we just win the game on
the spot so nothing for uh for this
bingo here uh so he did prepare uh
something very interesting as you've
seen uh for hikaru but it just
wasn't enough and he was really really
trying to win this hikaru didn't take
much risks
and there were a couple of instances
where ispenko could have just gone for
the draw
but he really wanted to win this game
and in the end he lost it and hikaru
gets a spot in the uh
the next candidates tournament and uh as
the and no one else will be able to
catch up to rapport as most of the uh
people with with a lot of points wherein
hikaru's group that means uh rihard
rapport and hikaru nakamura have
qualified for the candidates tournament
now what does this mean uh for the
entire tournament do we have all the
participants well no we still have to
wait for ding ding is still playing uh
he still needs to
have enough classical games played in
order to
be qualified for the for the classical
event uh that is the candidates
tournament uh but he's doing great he
today i think he already won his fourth
classical game in a row and he is uh not
just winning the games but he's also
increasing his classical rating he's
already i think he overtook furuja now
as the on the live rating list i could
be wrong uh but uh i think if not then
he is extremely close i think i think
he's like 2804 already
and he was at 27.99 when he started his
ascent uh so yeah this is uh extremely
extremely exciting we know all the
participants now except for ding
and we'll see what what ding will do
most likely he will be able to qualify
but i mean
you can never uh
be certain
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said espanko was uh
i mean he was extremely prepared you've
seen he had everything but he really
really wanted to win this game uh and
that's why that's why he lost it uh so
yeah uh i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank david kimura mcmahon
open sea smokey
bernard for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
grand prix until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day